it is October the first today my name is
Jess McDonald and your children to
gamespot news first up a major destiny
patch is landing with some pretty sweet
additions Pat one point oh boy to his
mate strike missions more rewarding and
altered the way that n grams are earned
and claimed engrams being unidentified
items you're given for killing lots of
dudes or what have you basically the
gist is that you'll have a higher chance
of getting rare and legendary drops from
more missions in addition to that
legendary engrams will always produce a
legendary quality item or higher from
now on and rare and grants will always
produce a rare quality item or higher
something which was not always the case
and the big point of grief for most
gamers for the full list of changes you
can head to gain [ __ ] and check out our
story next up shadow of mordor dev
monolith productions say just because
they game sort of looks plays and feels
like Assassin's Creed does not make it
Assassin's Creed and also a lot of folks
have been making comparisons between the
two titles including former yippie dev
Charles Randall who accused one lip of
using AC code and assets in their game
nonetheless lead designer Bob Roberts
said shadow of mordor has loads making
it stand out such as the Nemesis feature
where enemies you've killed or have been
killed by will come back to haunt you
with a vengeance Robert suspects once
people play the game they'll realize how
different it is he also touched on the
creative liberties the game is taken
with the Lord of the Rings narrative
explaining we did the very best job we
could as diehard Tolkien fans ourselves
and we have a lot of people paying close
attention to make sure we're as
authentic as we can be and finally a
couple of hackers have pleaded guilty to
infiltrating Microsoft and trying to
build a count of it Xbox one the
geniuses and I mean that both literally
and with a heavy dose of mocking
admitted to being part of a hacker ring
which stole code from the then
unreleased years of war three and they
hacked into valves internal network to
steal a beta build of modern warfare 3
in 2011 then in 2012 the group dug into
Microsoft's employee network and stole
the assembly instructions software
designs and source code for the Xbox one
the counterfeit system was built and
reportedly sold for over 20 grand the
hackers are also accused of helping
burglars steal beta versions of the xbox
one in 2013 among other things and all
up they're expected to have caused
damages of over 100 million in
intellectual property and data that's
your question of the day let me know
what you guys think of all this company
infiltration and hacking if you're after
more news we've got stories on things
like the sims 4 getting pools and the PS
Plus games you can grab the free this
month on gamespot those are all the good
things that I wanted to tell you about
today i'll be back same time and place
tomorrow so i hope to see you then